كانت
الطلباتهم او الاوامر صارمه جدا
وتتجاوز حدود الجوانب الامنيه
ولم تكن مقوله من قبلي مثل مثلا عليك ان
لا عليك عليك ان تصافحه فقط وان لا تضموا
بالضبط ولا تتبادل معه على الطريقه
العراقيه او الطريق الشرقيه
لا تحترم الرئيس
انت محامي ونحن نحترم المحامين وهو مجرم
وضعنا طاولتين بينك وبينها انت راح تكون
منهم يعني من جهه الحائط حتى ما يعني
الارتفاع للطاولات لا تسمح لي النهوض
وعدد يعني كبير من من الاوامر الصارمه
كل طبيعه هذه الطلبات والاوامر التي كانوا
يريدون ان يملوها علي
واجهتها بالرفض المطلق فكان نقاش يعني
بيني وبين العقيد الضابطه الامريكي نقاش
حاد ورفضت كل الطلبات اللي
يعني بالاخر قلت لهم يعني طلبت منهم ان
يعيدوني الى حيث اتوا به الى النقطه صفر
فبهذه بهذا الاثناء كان شد وجذب بيني
وبينهم دخلت علينا الجهراء الامريكيه
وكانت يعني تمزح وسلمت باللغه العربيه
وتدخلت قالت لي يعني ماذا تريد قلت لها
انا كل الطلبات اللي طلبتوها من عندي
مرفوضه لانه هاي تحط من كرامه الرئيس ومن
قدر الرئيس وانتوا جايبوه يعني انتم اتيتم
انتم اتيتم الى هنا لكي
تحاولوا اهانه الرئيس وهذا غير مقبول هذا
رئيسي فقالت لي هذا رجل انتهى من يعني من
السلطه وهو الان يحاكم بجرائم دوليه قلت
لها
الوصف الذي تصفيه هذا من جانبكم انتم اما
انا الرئيسي الشرعي وخلقه وخلعتوه بالقوه
قوه العسكريه
فانا احترم حدودي واحترم مهنتي واحترم
قسمي واحترم اخلاقي والمبادئ التي تربيت
عليها تعامل مؤقت اذا اعجبكم هذا الوضع
فخير فبها ولم يعجبكم
فاعدوني بالاخير امام اصراري وافقت قالت
لكل طلباتكم مجابه قلت لها اذا تخرجون احد
الطاولات وتخلون طاوله يعني
ومو مرتفعه تمام واخرجوها يعني اخرجوا
وخلوا طاوله يعني يعني ارتفاعها مقبول